all right i am picking up
20 minutes into the titled arena
december
2021 with
dr championstein
aka magnus carlson
i played a handful of games in this
titled arena
and saw he was playing
so cut out
i want to track the doctor
his latest handle
mr five-time champion
hello in the chat
so we're going to catch the final hour
hour 40 minutes of this one
carlson is currently in fifth
all right i think we're now squared away
so
he just lost that last game on time
all right and dropped 68 points
still has a question mark for the rating
all right
so we should be getting another one
anytime soon
i am following him
there we go all right i think we're all
squared away this is the last minute
a last minute thing firing up this
stream so we'll see how it goes
currently in ninth
we'll have a look at the standings after
this game real quick
yeah i see in the chat he is he's
definitely a fan of this the
steins a lot of steins for usernames
drunkenstein necterstein championstein
the doctor
alright this knight coming into that d5
square is concerning me
these these dark squares
this knight had a different idea knight
b6 was
watching over that d5 post there goes
the
queen and white resign so standings
let's have a look at them
he's currently in fourth which is 25
in first is vladimirovich
aka
uh dimitri and draken
okay next opponent nm jusugi
space
for carlson
c6 pawn is a bit soft
this bishop's going to have a tough day
at the office
big problem here superior structure for
white good square for the knight but
it's offset by this guy
this is i don't foresee this bishop
really seeing the light of day
bishop a5 can be a move
not even allowing this possibility to
open up a new diagonal
rook e5 with what is the idea there
this rook feels a little misplaced
might be trapped i guess knight there
there's rook here so bishop a5 no
doubling on the d file tough to kick
this bishop away
space
maybe g5 though there is maybe a knight
h4 move
preparing to have the bishop on e4 soon
there could be some tricks in the end if
there's a a capture on d4
really in the tank now team black tough
to find a way to improve the pieces from
here
queen exchange
queen exchange and now how are we
defending this bishop c3 there's b4
so that's not a fun move to make this
rook is unprotected so you can't take on
this square
changing the attention now to this we're
going to have the exchange of the center
pawns still white is better
ready to
grab the knight and then the pawn
uh white managed well in this
position oh now this is going to be a
win even though it's opposite color
bishops i believe these two past
these two past pawns will
secure the victory
yeah now this bishop is free to do
whatever
yeah this king the king is tethered to
the defense of the pawn
okay jizugi goes down
carlson now in
the sixth spot so the other players
rebecca harris
naraditsky
is in there
min lee as well
um
not sure who wild king 91 is
okay i don't know who this international
master is but a very high rating
29.57
hello in the chat
okay we have a square here on d5
isolated pawn
all three miners coordinated well
queen's unprotected
g2
in the crosshairs
um problems now possible pins following
up
immediately
this night it's in the center but it's
vulnerable
you could take here
it's a resigner i guess
this guy was in the seventh spot
resigns
where's that put him
dr championstein 31 with fire
vladimirovich
not on fire
all right we will see
okay next step
d4 incoming oh running right into a fork
is this
this can't be some
theory
is it
what's the trick here you have a fork if
you defend the knight
or if here then
is there some trick
okay trying to get out of this pin first
of all
swipe the knight
and f3 king f2
how are we getting out of this okay f4
king f2 or that
okay
there's a trick here on f6
he's calculating it
you could always take here and if king
hear you do this first
taking like this
two minor pieces versus the rook
a past pawn the king is cut off
maybe he could get away with pushing and
then get to the rook and get the rook to
the seventh rank
he's down on the clock
okay this rook is really active but
there is coordination now i think the
the bishop right here controls all pawn
breaks
getting rolling with the king side pawns
taking away from the center keep upon
past
there's control over this break
how dangerous is this pawn the king can
stop it it's not gonna be easy
yeah
okay they've been broken up oh that's a
nice move
oh another nice move not taking you drop
the knight so fast
and now the knight is there just in time
to track this pawn down
king defends this the bishop haunts that
one to secure the draw at minimum
he's going to continue pushing made on
the spot there we go okay
he's on a roll keeping the fire in the
second spot
35 one win away from first performance
rating so far 31-21
uh he
this was probably i'm not sure what day
this was created probably probably just
hours ago
this account
okay bononi structure incoming
yes
important for white to stop this
94 move freeze up the bishop easily
a soft spot here on d6
queen is under fire
the bishop is under fire is this knight
there's some problems here with the
knight
isn't isn't the knight going to get
tracked down
it's getting tracked down so he's going
to try and complicate
where is the compensation though
not seeing it
yet
maybe you take here first
you know the bishop can block
this is not going well for team black
king towards the center two bishops this
guy is not contributing it's the only
hope
what's wrong with that what's the
follow-up bishop block oh they're
supporting the queen there
key defender the bishop on g3 this is
the glue to the position there goes
another piece
uh but then the rook would follow a
check
tricky tricky
black resigned though there is no
crashing through on the g-file and these
guys are
animals
so the doctor goes down and now he's
faced
paired up against the wild king
the number six guy
as a big loss
he would have been in the first spot
39 points
so we will see yes he is streaming right
here
in hour 28 to go
so the knight stand well this is a nice
jumping point g4
to free up the bishop i guess b4 nearby
where does the king feel safe
it's unclear
i don't know if it's any safer on the
king side than in the center
in between or first something
can't take with the rook because there's
rook takes knight
and there's still rook takes tonight oh
cause you're on this one so now we on
the queen and threatening mate just out
of
out of the mate
threat
and the queen's fret with queen g5
minor pieces versus the rook
fancy
fancy damage the structure
two bishops now versus the rook
good coordination
rook here
would be met with rook to d8 check
so you're not not winning the queen so
fast
good square for the bishop on d5
soon
yeah capturing with the queen
there'd be some pawn race
queen is really well placed and now the
rook is on the defensive so only
only after white is tied up to the
defense of c2
does black get rolling oh there goes the
passer
you could get a queen soon but first
centralization
can promote there are no perpetual
checks
and back he goes targeting c2
and this is mate
king is in a crossfire the wild king
goes down plenty of time in the tank as
well 802 8.2
37 he has
uh
and draken still in first with 43 and
fire
i don't know if they've played yet i
missed
maybe the first five or six games by
carlson
so we'll see
nice to have this file
an early capture on g3 before castles so
trying to eventually get some tempo
against this guy there is some
restriction still this is a move g5 rook
is unprotected the queen's defending
with that last move this could have been
a little bit irritating knight b5 as
soon as the king as soon as the knight
went here there goes d6
ripping the heart out of the
center structure now this knight is
off the charts act of rook d6 something
something bad is gonna happen here
this is defended oh is she dead she has
to go home oh
brutal
sacrifices here incoming
knight takes with check oh man g6 now
brutal
look at these pieces swarming in
too much
and the pawn you might as well count
this guy here as an attacker
where's the mate
got a check and the follow-up this is
covered black resigns doesn't want to
see anything further could always take
the queen maybe that would be best i
don't see the mate here
gets the w okay this guy again
their third their third game is having a
very good run
international master
okay what do we have here this
chebanenko slav i believe it is
a quick knight to e5
a quick assault against c6
so this is a weak pawn
g5
aggressive no king knight around
so i wonder if that's a quick thought
that runs through the doctor's mind you
know what i don't think you could take
advantage of these weaknesses i'll be
more aggressive create a flight square
a developing square for my bishop okay
so now keying in on the light squares oh
that's a good spot this is a resigner i
believe
bishop's bishop's toast so white is up a
piece
again now we have knight here and mate
oh no the king is slipping out oh but
that's me
wow
what a run this guy's blitz rating is
2809 currently
and now he's approaching 3 000.
probably one of those
gm's to be maybe maybe already a gm
elect who knows
maybe they have it in the
profile okay min lee bishop here is met
with
uh d take c
so now
do we take the queen and allow these
double isolated pawns no we don't
how do we babysit this
okay
that's how we're
reorganizing
didn't want to capture on d5 that's
going to help straighten out white
structure black still wants to play with
this center and now it is rolling
there is a pin here
center is being challenged though this
is a little uncomfortable for the queen
i believe
all right white has picked up the bishop
pair
now maybe c5 okay doesn't want to see
this majority rolling there is
uh you know three versus two
prep work for that now the night this
post is questioned
will be questioned soon follow-up fork
could go back home to defend the bishop
now he's okay with the doubled
the doubled pawns on the king's side
queen on g4
should secure a lot of the
the weak points
and now what
white is up the exchange
heavy fire now on f3 this is
a serious pawn ooh
still going in here bishop takes
and then rook up and over these all
these pieces are working
knight takes on this square would have
been good as well
knight g4
wow
oh so slick this is now going to be hit
three times but look at the clock
you gotta you gotta win by mate maybe
taking there was better oh this isn't
gonna go good
one position
but
clock
clock clock clock
the doctor got clocked on that one 14
seconds up min lee
a past winner of this event
and draken still
in the lead there with 55.
also
we have clever tactic but fail in there
andrew tang
don't forget about him
another past winner of this event
okay fmrob188
a quick assault
by harry the h-pawn
the knight had to find a new home on g3
so what are we doing about this pawn
here a lot of focus on this in the early
stage bishop
c4 nearby pressure on f7 now how are we
defending this do we castle
he's defending with the queen oh no the
bishop was there
as well to defend the pawn
so this guy
e4 under fire bishop pair for white
knight is under control
and i believe that this is collapsing
now and this this pawn is
ready to rumble
continue oh brutal crashing through rook
takes you're gonna pick up the bishop
yeah this is this is killing
i guess maybe there was knight here
defending
yeah
knight having a field day here
e6 c5
queen knifing in maybe a bishop enters
taking the knight first and then this
you take with the pawn the king
doesn't have access to b7
brutal
could offer a queen exchange there is no
taking the bishop we have the pin
and the time brutal 31 to nine in the
end
where is he at the fourth spot
he's back 14
okay this guy again what was the opening
here
it's looking like an exchange
royal lopez
okay some space for a start on the queen
side
gearing up for f4 f4 on board so now
there's
this point
so the last two games against this guy
carlson ended up dropping a piece
queen exchange
b2
i want to take b2 why not
oh maybe
i'm not sure why
why not that one
okay king side broken up a thorn pawn
brutal look at that move
you get to recapture with check take my
queen i take your queen and then this is
all gonna collapse
okay very active white rooks there
should be something here look at taking
a time out to preserve the b-pawn
uh how do you break this down though
clearly in a prevent team black
how do you smash through here he's in
the tank
you're running the numbers
okay not a fun move to make
running in reverse like this so the old
rook up and over you have to watch watch
out for the back rank we have a thorn
pawn here for black now
so a good defender for the king also
maintains pressure this is probably a
best piece in the position
okay so turning technical
you wanted to seal that pawn in there
good move i believe by black with d4 but
the clock situation a big big factor
right now
doesn't want this pawn just yet working
on the king position this rook is
tethered to the defense of this guy
and now this is getting broken down
another thorn pond this is a game of
thorn ponds game of thorns
no time though
oh my goodness this guy's cruising
that's his third win out of four games
impressive
okay he's in the second spot
the doctor
having a rough stretch here 41 still in
first and draken with 57 clever tactic
but fail
andrew tang
here we go
what are we gonna get
king's indian defense
let us see
this is a
this is very fisher-esque
to uh
have this messed up king side structure
i believe this was even played at the
with with the gambit
i'm losing losing this pawn
fisher playing with black what do we
have going on here bishop ready to knife
in queen h4 brutal
oh
so this czech king here queen there
queen here
i guess queen h4 queen e1 is a good
reply the only reply
so he knows it
so he's taking the material
so
now we have it balanced no
i mean it is balanced but the dark
squares how do we feel about the dark
squares
can you stop this f4 move
well i can get can get this grip over
the dark squares that's going to be
painful for white
clock
oh that's me
oh no the knight is covering that square
good grief
all right this guy's ready to move
that's why he didn't bite on e5
that would hurt
under 10 seconds for andrew but he is
the slipperiest player you'll find
very very slippery
to beat him on the board
almost every time
four seconds
so fast
now you could take that the bishop is
there
no stalemates
no stalemates
could have almost been a stalemate maybe
right around there
wow
wasn't it 28 to 14 at one point in the
end 1.1 to zero
he won that on time and position drop
stone next where does that put him
he's in the eighth spot has some work to
do with an hour 15 to go
okay what do we have here
solid structure for white bishop hair
for black
big gaps here in white's camp so
he gets out of that for starters don't
want to see a knight anchored into d3
really be asking for trouble
okay this is a passer
and it's it's a rolling
it's gonna be hunted maybe hunted
knight here no knight d5 threatens the
night threatens a possible fork in
coming the dark squares are very weak
if the bishop moves the knight jumps in
here
gets the material back the queen does a
good job securing the king
knight there and then knight here on c6
exchanging rooks first and then knight
c6 check
there's an unprotected rook here maybe
you don't have to react to this threat
just yet queen b3
queen exchange and then rook d2 queen
queen d2 straight away
maybe here within this but this is
hanging and there'll be a problem on f7
i don't think there's time to form the
battery on the back rank
this knight remains
on board white securing the back ring
king sneaking over in a prevent now on
f2 exploiting the pin queen takes e3
getting the queens off queen f3 queen f3
minor piece imbalance still
knight now struggling the queen guarding
a lot of its squares
up on the clock though the doctor
this one's going to be tough
tough for drop stone
that's falling
okay this is secure now it's evening out
on the clock oh but there goes the queen
both queens are now gone look at the
look at the quick move retreating there
this is a one king and pawn ending
fancy look at that triangulation you
gotta love it
triangulation look at how quick that was
executed
both queens
were toast there
and then we go down to a king and pawn
ending
so slick
triangulation
okay
a game of tempe
king and pawn endings
all right black has a pretty sweet
center
swiping the knight next looking to take
here the knight kicked away
to the center
he's okay with giving up multiple pawns
if we have this this here there's a it
was a possibility to take with check but
there'd be a lot of pressure i believe
against white
so he's getting out of any checks there
goes d4 and now queen here there's
bishop g3 you'd lose a bishop
tempting but bad
and now we have bishop takes f6 so this
next up
no is taking on b7 first queen exchange
nearby bishop pair
for team black
balanced material
f2 in the crosshairs
what are we doing about this even after
a queen exchange there's a problem here
maybe e3 oh e3 brutal
take on this square
not just
yet night there right away good that the
king isn't on this square oh fancy
what's happening here
i can have a check and then rook here
wow
so slick usually you see that with the
queen and still in the home square and
getting to h4 but
yeah there is that one as well maybe
this because you could defend like that
what was dismissed there
oh there was a queen exchange
i didn't realize the queens were in
tension
gets the skewer this is covered
take the rook and then take the pawn
how does he want to do it oh so fancy
inserting some checks first wants to
take with
bishop oh and if the king went over it
would have been mate
time time time
let's see how it goes
he's so fast
down on time
the slippery andrew tang
wow okay man
manchester united pro again min lee
where does that put them
where does that put him he's in the
seventh spot okay
still an hour ten to go are we gonna get
a comeback here
wow
let us see
the pin wouldn't have been a problem
there's always knight takes night it's
hitting with check black is up upon
black with the bishop pair the more
aggressive queen but
is there really enough attacking force
each side i think wants to have their
kings on g2 g7 and the rook on h1
h8 white has that in this is a good
defender
okay that's
that always feels like a bit of a
dangerous pawn to take
okay it's gonna get something here
how do you get out of this pin i don't
know if you want to really touch the f
pawn
really weak in the
second rank with still all major pieces
on board
okay maybe queen back to e2 now rook h4
defending the bishop
i don't know if you want to really
double here unless you could get a third
major piece
on the h file you're not really i think
in a way you're out of play
rook takes pawn i wonder what would have
happened there maybe maybe some bishop
takes g3 i'm not sure
okay h file again the clock last time it
was 14 to zero
favor of min lee it's looking good
position wise for white being up now two
pawns i
totally missed that that was even the
thing
yeah white is uh lights up a couple
pawnees and now hunting f7
oh but
the bishop is getting hunted min lee
taking a second game from the doctor
ahadir ozen
wow
long time since i've seen uh
bahadir ozen playing in one of these
super duper fast player strong
international master
2861
yeah look at my score by the way too
one in 25.
crazy
okay
a positional game
big point here on c4
better bishop
across the board
two instances of fixed pawns
okay now we have a good knight versus
bad bishop and white in control of the
only open file the bishop tethered to
the defense of the pawn this knight
can't really get rid of it
rook d4 is glued in with b3 also c3 so
we're transitioning
minor p specific ending
and i believe you could look forward to
this maybe you take with the king so
that you can get this in and then a
passer yep that's what he's shooting for
outside past pawn
it is on board
how do you win it
go hunting this pawn
he was threatening knight there so now
the king is pulled away some pawn moves
a little bit the knight's going to
recycle to where not here bishop has
that
jump around maybe here
okay knight on c4
king improving you can't take it's a one
king and pawn ending
was that knight maybe just up for grabs
for a second was the were the king and
bishop on that at one point
there's the bishop
tricky knight
does
does the trick again
this guy's time doesn't go anywhere
it's crazy
so fast
wow finally an 83 mover five seconds in
the tank the doctor takes that one
now in the eighth spot 49 in first and
draken with 69 and fire
that's gonna be a tough one to make up
okay this guy again
is in the third spot
international master
three to one
so far for the i am
let's go dr champion stein let's see
let us see
he's clinging to an extra pawn but
these are real
real killers now
that c6 pawn
problem here
how do you get out of this
okay i guess you could take here first
wow
ready to glue the bishop in
a4
two passers
these bishops
killers
up on the clock
there goes the queen the queen was
defending that wow
yeah this one's gone
again four four out of five games
one for this international master crazy
okay how do you convert this we improved
the pawns here for white
get the king involved
all these are required to neutralize
this configuration so
at any point the knight could be
captured and then this that was an
opportunity for it
it's also paving the way for this with
the queen on e4
12 to 6 on the clock black just resigned
knight takes queen we promote
wow
4 out of 5 for that i am pushing the
doctor
into the 11th spot
okay
in the chat chess poems is saying this
is some 15 year old that's why he's
faster than magnus is that true oh yeah
i don't know
what the story is with that that player
clearly
very strong play there
min lee is another
super duper strong i am
who's up what was it now he's up
did he win two games against carlson as
well
okay give me a break
and the break is f5
oh that's a big pawn to drop off there
night not having the the greatest
the greatest time
gonna get this guy
didn't want to take here because it
helps out the rook
crushing position two passers
one is tracked down
and the other one we got back up
got a wave of pawns
back ranked mates
backrank mate was there one move sooner
i think
maybe he's having a laugh at missing the
backranker instead the pawn push
that happens
okay where does that put him is he still
on page two no back up to page one with
51 still 20 back with an hour to go
rebecca harrison second matthew g
in third 65s
msb2 next up
king's indian attack
okay
oh yes i'm seeing uh
in the chat you're pointing out the
material tracker yeah i i took that off
when i was covering the world
championship
um
i could put that back on
another time
let's see what's happening here so a sac
aroni
on h6 you take my bishop i take your
knight
we have queen here nearby the bishop
could come back to defend
not a fun move by the night the queen
though is she close to trapped no she
isn't she runs back home
gets rid of the isolated pawn and now
jumps on in he is up a pawn
this bishop is unprotected queen has a
responsibility and this one's dead there
goes the rook ah look at look at the
fancy move you know i want to take your
rook with check let's see if you're
going to go to the back rank first
oh there'd be a perpetual though you
can't take the rook so soon
the queen was on f2
so you had to secure this point first
okay now everything should be secure
base points covered
yep that's gonna do it
boom boom
we have an hour one to go the doctor's
in tenth with 53 and fire it's been a
while since he's hit a four oh
it's about 12 games since he's hit a
four
n m and jatsugi
i believe jatsugi was recently playing
crazy house
some event crazy house is it a world
chess
world championship crazy house anyhow
it's fantastic
regular chess player of course and
maybe an even even better crazy house
player one of the one of the very best
in the world
and is always up here
page two page one it seems
more often than not
what's going on in this one
king's having a tough time are there
mates
the knight can block on f3 if there's a
rook check so he just gets that right
right back now the knight is hit twice
the bishop is taking this one first
wants to take this next and then this
one
one should be gone though i don't think
he could get out of that up next is f5
you can also think about taking here and
the bishop is defending the rook
all right
white throws in the towel
and
he's in the 8 spot with 57 in first 73
matthew g
another one of those ims you'll see that
i turn into a g
not long off from now
and i imagine
okay
big square here on d5 for white these
squares is the big difference
one is a whole and the other is not
down a piece he gets it back
there might be some tactic on
this square possibly a bishop on e4
maybe something on h7 the bishop wants
to be
on this diagonal
white keying in on f7 bishop on c4 soon
perfect coordination for white bishop c4
the bishops under control by the
structure
there goes f7
bishop c4 bishop on b3
to watch about this square though
careful now oh so fancy with the back
rank tricks look at that
another fancy reply i got the recovered
oh there goes f2 with check
check on board if the king went to a
light square the bishop would have been
excited this is secure on g3
that's a fancy move
okay
clock situation two to one
fancy move queen takes a2 the rook is
still secure there
that's a big pawn
a really big pawn you have to go for a
perpetual or what
facing mate
you have to take the perpetual
wow
okay matthew g
strong player
and quite the stretch
wow a lot of fours there
the doctor where is he at now up against
blue green sun
he's in the seventh spot
all right
c
pawn
bononi
so that's c4 looking to distract the
defense of the e4 pawn
a lot of space here for black there are
some gaps can they be
exploited the big one is c6 have to take
some good care over that one
as soon as this knight moves this knight
will be excited about c6
maybe ready to be offset as soon as it
jumps in knight e5 we challenge this guy
some way no first you push
rook takes here the knight can recapture
and be defending the rook
is there some other move okay so
queen is cornered
white is up upon
big center here
still very complicated
tricks now with knight takes
in this position if the rook was if they
were capture the pawn on c3
this one is secure
good coordination for white a past pawn
team black here rook is now hit the
knight is jumping around maybe a2 falls
the bishop is gone the a pawn falls two
past pawns three pass pawns bishop pair
no bishop
offering queen exchange give me the two
connected past pawns
you could always block with the bishop
oh
allowing the queen
with check
there goes the rook
two queens is too many 11 seconds each
blue green sun throws in the towel where
we at
61
16 back
rebecca harris now in first and draken
right on his heels
narditzky's heels
who are we getting next oh the slippery
guy clever tactic but fail mr andrew
tang
game number three
okay another line with this
bishop takes on c3 excuse me c6
exchange
roy lopez
okay important to have this rook
defended queen d4
the rook goes into the pin voluntarily
interesting the knights are falling on
good squares the queen is way too
invasive challenge this is the best
piece in the position
gearing up for a4 and now there's c4 is
a weakness big big squares for team
white
g4 supported by the knight excellent
grip
can improve the king soon no he's not
going to have the h file open up
i have control over the only open file
that's what he's saying
and now where do we go here how do we
break this position
it's not fun
for black to have to just go back and
forth but there isn't really a great way
to improve
what's he looking to do maybe this
in a try and target c5 okay knight f4
can't can't take twice we have this pin
not quite sure why that one wasn't
played oh the bishop has a move to
defend the rook
okay
technical now
doesn't allow the king to get to d5 he's
going to try this square though king and
pawn ending
how do we feel about the king and pawn
ending it'll be winning if the rook
captures here he would have opposition
wow
just barely
you don't want to take here
problem there okay hunting for pawns now
who's going to win
the clock
the clock is going to be a big factor
the usual case
time burners
okay he's hunting the rook
seven seconds
up
andrew tang throws in the towel the
doctor now in
seventh with 63 and fire 15 back with 53
to go
and draken
oh so they must have played
when i wasn't uh streaming
one of those first five or six games
that i missed
ah that was probably his first loss then
i saw i saw a zero and
a bunch of wins
in his first handful
careful over the c6 square
don't want to budge too soon with the
knight now if we're in a
minor piece or excuse me a major piece
specific position i like black
notice not capturing here this would be
a really good square for the king
so we're getting this guy rolling at
some point h5
okay the these major pieces are all
finding pretty good squares
now this is
this could be annoying to defend
and the rook is well positioned stopping
this break
with h4
so how do we improve here king up
yeah this should be a draw i'm not
seeing any progress now
it's going to try and open up
i mean if anything white is playing for
something i believe
because these three pawns restrict these
four so there can soon be a passer on
the
king side yeah this rook is really
active now white is clearly for choice
uh but there are a bunch of checks not
going to be easy
get behind this one
this guy could run fast threatening mate
rook check king here
okay now we have a passer
time i think you could you could time
burn your way at minimum oh
okay he's okay with this
he knows that he could
take him down to zero
the doctor takes that one
big game right here
min lee
the doctor's now in sixth
51 minutes to go
what was this a scandinavian is that how
it started
scandinavian queen side castles
a2 is secure this knight is securing f7
now a trick oh within the queen playing
here
and then the follow-up what
okay
okay if the knight goes here there would
be c4 c4 anyway oh
killer bishops man
with c5 nearby
there's also this one
if you take the pawn pinarones
queen and knight cannot go too far
okay
now check
you don't want to go to the go to the c
file you're asking for trouble keeping
the bishop around
trying to eliminate this guy he's up
eight seconds this time maybe definitely
the first time now he's up sometime
against min lee
there goes g7
excellent position for white position
wise clockwise
yes i was going to say flight square and
a a ram
is this guy toast could take here
yeah we could go into this ending up
upon
hunting this guy no he's taking this
with check a resigner here
uh it's evening out on the clock how
much more do we play yeah
three connected passers soon
min lee throws in the towel in first
rebecca harris
82 72
8278 the doctor at 71 11 back with fire
though
in fourth the only one of the top what
six with fire rebecca harris big game
let's see we get
always it always seems to be tactical
with mr narditzky
let's see
what type of position we get i feel like
if it's super complicated
it uh it usually goes in
narditzky's favor
let us see well
how fun is it to have the king on d1
it's
imbalanced
structure wise bishop wise
minor piecewise
i think after c4 gets
c4 gets met with d5
still trying to get this king
breathing okay the king's on d2 this is
turned strategic
more much more technical now i don't
believe you want to take the rook
straighten out the pawns
wouldn't mind seeing this now the knight
wants to get to this square
yep so this guy is going to be hunted
the king is sealed off
time
not too much of a factor one king and
pawn ending
insert the check soon
maybe play this before that one no he's
getting rolling here
two passers the king superior king
position superior minor piece
it's down a bit on the clock though
these guys could get rolling oh he's
picking up another pawn
and going for another
yeah
i don't know how much
more there is to complicate
oh so fancy he could afford to take that
one out and now it's too smooth a ride
he's gonna play this one out still with
seven nope he resigns okay so that's a
huge win
against the number one guy nardinski
goes down
84 the doctor with fire 75 only 9 back
now
411 in here
let's see
next up another gm
all right
what do we have a killer bishop
much better bishop
for white
majority for black on the queen side but
it is
not yet felt as
a positive i don't believe
uh some rook c6 move may have been there
but i no longer think that with the pawn
on e5 maybe maybe after this
planting a rook on c6 but for now black
has good control over this square and is
hunting
hunting the a pawn but now there's a
thorn pawn on h6
possible battery looking for mate
some pressure on f2
there is f6 as a reply unnecessary reply
king ready to step up to g2
meanwhile these guys get rolling
this with the capture and then queen e5
was nearby so sensing that he wants to
get the queens off and now he has to
watch out for this runner
also the back rank mate
okay the bishops are covering the
squares
maybe just keep the tension
okay
along that capture
take this guy
can block everything is now under
control still no back ranker back rank
mate king slides over
yeah and they whoa it's still covered
again
how quickly this is recognized look at
the clock though
five to nine
okay
three seconds each
two to one
oh he gets it the doctor with the w a
big win putting him in the number two
spot with 79
he has quite the stretch here
79 with fire only seven back
dr championstein minli
next up
ah these are a blast
i love it
okay we got the break
think after a chopperoni there's knight
knight h5
okay d6
d6 are we taking d6 ever is there going
to be a trick here the queen is hit
it's a problem on this square this one's
this one's again but this one's again
do we even want to take that pawn no
we're safeguarding this guy first
taking the knight next now we get to
recapture with check and be defending
our our pawn
this is under fire look at how many
how many games this point is sensitive
right this is the weakest point at the
beginning of the game and very often
even in an end game
that f7 square right next to the kings
33 to 29 on the clock
black up two pawns
same color bishops this is secure
a new flight square for the king
offer a queen exchange
okay now h2
careful about h2 base points covered
queen perfect on this central square
guarding the king guarding the pawn we
have some tricks
so fancy queen takes pawn there would
have been rook f1 you need to end up
losing the queen for a rook
let's see the technique
let's see the technique a queen on this
square or a queen guarding this diagonal
both are good
there's the check
yep
diagonal's covered and the pawn is ready
to go king is secure no perpetuals
another win by the doctor
one two three four five six seven games
now in a row
putting him in the second spot only five
back let's see pressure on b7 now
okay
e4 break
queen is hit
where does she go there's gonna be an
unprotected piece here there is right
now
c6 can fall
you don't want to take it now he's
saying i want to see your knight move
then i want to take here maybe there's
some forks
okay bishop pear oh what an animal of a
bishop on g2
doesn't even want to take that right
away with some follow-up here oh he
wants the rook and he's getting the
brutal a resigner here
a resigner
oh sad day for that night on b8 how does
he do it 87 now with fire
and draken this this win right here puts
him in first
a grunfeld on board
okay
take care over the dark squares now
white
down the exchange but has a super
dangerous dark square bishop
looking to break it down further with e5
black sensing danger wants the queen's
off
no thank you
i have the safer king white says
i want f6 maybe this and then that or
this and then that
no not that sequence the queen would be
on f6
it's scary here
very scary ah what a move bishop take oh
that's really sweet
yeah bishop t there's a fork here you're
gonna win a rook however you slice it
maybe end up getting mated
it's pretty bad
okay the doctor finally
goes down
not so fast he is not in first rebecca
harris is though up five with fire
narditzky
okay
where's the compensation
okay oh
here's the compensation well you're
getting the pawn back and now big
question mark over the king
where is your safe shelter
okay he's getting another pawn
those two are hit
the
technique i think he wins these games 99
out of 100 times
let's see
oh my goodness and did i just jinx him
there
wow did he walk into that one
he gave away a free this might be the
one one game out of the hundred then oh
oh man
oh
right king f3
so natural to move right you play that
before some
just get out of any pins address any any
threats there the game is still live
though
let's see this pawn can be hunted
this is a runner though it's looking
pretty dangerous you don't want to take
here
so get out of the way of the pawn and
then push it
there isn't a mate over here but now
he's stirring up some trouble the clock
clock clock
there's a check here you got to
sacrifice a rook for a pawn soon throw
in some time burners fancy he's going
with the other rook first and now this
guy is hunted
four pawns
okay check first
i think he's gonna take this one
it's not so easy for black
wow even though he might just be winning
objectively holy smokes
he is
a queen is on the scene two queens on
the scene made around the corner
wow
did he come back
or what
[Laughter]
down a bishop who needs a bishop
really
i don't need that bishop
all right so that was still one of the
99 out of the hundred games okay 96 with
fire narditzky
the doctor back eight
it's uh this is awesome seeing
these guys all in here they're all so
good
such a competitive event
and draken again
and draken up 2-1 against the doctor in
this
tournament
under 40 to go
still unclear i do not expect some
runaway at this point with only 40
minutes to go it is way way way too
competitive
anything can still happen
who is going to have the better nerves
let's see
okay this does not make a great
impression here these double isolated
pawns
um
yeah this is a bit concerning very very
active
rook
to babysit the
the pawn here there may be some accident
on g6 at some stage
slight edge on the clock
to watch out for this one there's pins
how do we how do we make progress do you
try and
play f5 here how do you improve he's
doubling rooks
feels a little scary
like you're ready to get smothered mated
okay
okay knight getting into d4 and then c6
and then this guy will fall though and
they're neat it feels like there needs
to be some trick here maybe maybe this
with this at some point but i believe f5
will be met with g5
still have to watch out for this if this
knight goes too far knight g3 could land
so after a bishop move a capture here
within this maybe nearby he doesn't want
to budge with the bishop
the knight has a big responsibility of
negating the knight on h5 he's under 10
seconds 13 for team black
pressure on f3 it is secure though the
knights pouncing one of them is gone
queen takes h6 with check both no
there's he's up with the queen he's
threatening mate
rook b6 you have to go back
he only has a second
did he have made he has mate with .03
oh my goodness
can you believe that that's ridiculous
point
zero
three
[Laughter]
hundreds
three hundredths of a second
what a game okay
a hundred for nardinski a huge game
right here 35 in change remaining that
was a ridiculous game
okay
oh what is this one uh another royal
lopez a uh
schliemann
is that what this one is
the quick f5
schliemann land
okay is he prepared to go queen side
black
no he's going king's side
as soon as the bishop
tried to
neutralize the pin and get out of the
pin the knight looking for this square
that would have been an annoying pawn to
work around so
gets rid of the f pawn and now an
isolated pawn
what is happening here at some point are
we gonna have this break wow takes a
time out just to swipe a pawn and now
he's going to win the exchange or the
queens are going to be off so he'd
rather have the
white up the exchange than to enter
a technical position
in
an equal position where you're just down
upon so
complicating
complicating it as best he can team
black
down on the clock
team white
oh so quick
i could afford to give up my queen i'll
get yours back in just a hair if i could
dress and draw a line
okay
complications complications still up the
exchange there's a check here the knight
if you got if it dives in it'll be
trapped after king to g2 another bad
line
outside pass pawn at some point
fancy knights careful careful a knight
right here could be dangerous he's
setting that up possibly no that pawn is
pinned
the rook is hit there goes the b pawn
seven seconds i'm going to give this one
to naraditsky
the clock
the clock
oh my goodness
four
seconds he's so quick
one second it's not going to be enough
nope naraditsky takes that a big big win
for nardinsky right there
the doctor isn't in second anymore
dropstone in the two spot 102 with fire
for narditzky rebecca harris still a lot
of tournament to go 33 minutes
okay he's pared down quite a bit no
first second
or third page opponent
international master in the 39 spot
all right let us see
space invader
pawn on e4
okay giving up the dark square bishop f4
now this is
feels like it is already
absolutely crushing
so that space invader pawn has been
challenged but now there's a weak link
on e3 and i'm not so sure you're getting
rid of it look at the grip these guys
have over that square
absolute monster of a bishop
queen g5 nearby
i'd even deal with that
gotta run for the hills
h2 is the hills
yeah there's no surviving that bishop
he resigns the doctor with a pretty
quick win 93 now rebecca harris still in
a game
no easy games
min lee is his opponent mainly up on the
clock there
32 to go fig lewd
next up
let's see
queen's gambit accepted is that what it
is here
all right
structures
the same
offset this guy right here one of the
better pieces in the position is this
guy going to get rolling bishop says not
so fast also stops any rook c1
might have been a dual purpose move
maybe a knight on b5 at some point okay
safeguard first
the second rank
we're having a little bit of a tough
time what's the
bishop here
wouldn't bishop there have trapped the
rook
i think it would have trapped the rook
bishop c3 okay the game goes on
the knight is dancing
yeah i think that guy was stuck for a
second okay not not anymore because the
the a pawn has
stepped up
so we have some checks maybe you have to
watch out yeah there was a mate threat
rookie one can you spare square so minor
piece ending
the king is boxed out with the knight
and pawn here is there is there progress
on
the king side and it's shut down on the
on the queen side so
we try our luck on this side of the
board
uh this is secure as well oh and he is
gonna get this now is the attempt gonna
be to capture and infiltrate yes it is
the king has to probably come back
yeah it's too risky to go here
this
check in here just in the nick of time
look at this guy so slippery
fancy fancy fancy
one king and pun ending coming up
wow okay with the w the doctor 95 with
fire 96 with fire drop stone 106
naraditsky
still with fire benko gambit declined i
guess with queen c2
not a gambit
in this case so
white doesn't want to see the a file
open up so easily
chop a6
so
nice pressure on the queen side
yeah now this pawn
and this knight isn't so great
white breaking in the center
it's prepared maybe to okay now i was
going to say maybe prepared to recapture
with the knight and put pressure on c4
pressure on this square now
d6 is vulnerable how we defending that
do you need to defend it
is defended
it's in the center now are there tricks
are there a sacrifice here you can't
move the knight that'd be made on h7
trying to neutralize this rook there
goes the rook can you afford to take
this pawn oh skewer it is defended by
the knight though
now we're gonna have the queen take the
pawn directly maybe insert a check
takes it directly this is a super
dangerous pawn white playing for it
seems
uh
two seems like two results defends the
knight it's ready to run this is a
dangerous pawn don't let it get here
no good checks for the white queen
this is also under control the knight
improves
we take here take here with check
clock times about even
still keeping a watchful eye over this
he missed this one with check and now
this pawn is able to advance white is
going to win this this is secure the
knight can grab the pawn he's getting a
queen first i'm not sure why
because we're going to have this as a
follow-up after queen and you get the
knight or probably have a resigner yep
doctor goes down
and a quick pairing
narditzky up 15
andrew tang next opponent that's going
to be a tough one to overcome
15 points down
with only 28 minutes to go
whoo man
let's see
light square bishops
gonzo
this is a half dead pawn
a knight on c5 now he's he's gonna pile
up first and now
expand in the center
with this majority
all right we're getting c5 in are there
tricks
this is secured by the knight
so capturing first only then taking here
that's a dangerous piece hitting the
rock hitting the bishop white's winning
some material here how much is the
question
he's getting the exchange there's some
tricks here with the queen getting here
not just yet
knight has some pressure on it don't go
too fast
maybe give up c8 there
still pressure on d6 black has a
majority but
i don't think he can get it rolling just
yet a4 would drop b4 there's pressure on
the bishop no good solution here yeah
he's ready to take the bishop and take
the knight and if the knight moves this
rook enters
big problems here
okay andrew tang throws in the towel
the doctor moves up to the 2 spot 13
back does not have fire needs to catch
fire soon
in order to make a run
dr championstein
all right let's see
grunfeld like
seems
so what do we have queen exchange rook
recapturing
c pawn's likely to fall
okay and now isn't
isn't there going to be the win of the
exchange bishop takes
okay now there's bishop takes h6 so
fancy but no still in the end this fork
is present
he's winning the exchange here
check
yep and now this is this is gonzo
yeah this will not be a
i'm gonna stay away from winning
the 99 out of 100 games
um
you know let's see
phase one is what glue that pawn in
there ah pivot square
that's the plan
pivot
it's it's a little
it's a little scary over okay the king
is gonna get this pun no problems once
this pawn is gone
and at some point there can maybe even
be the capture
all right
it's ready to get behind
wow now he's cut he's paving the way for
the king to approach there goes the
bishop now this pawn's ready to run
plenty of time in the tank
okay resigner the chameleon goes down
the doctor
now has fire but so does naraditsky
i think we're getting that game
nardiski just finished here we go huge
game if he's going to make a run
this is almost like a must-win
you're only going to get about 12 more
games in there
okay let's see how it goes
is there gonna be any problem here there
should be enough time to get development
in we're in an ending
nice rook activity for white
uh he's hunting this pawn
how quick that decision right you can't
take twice though there's a trick on the
end on h7
so he's saved the pawn the loss of d4
okay you want to maybe get out of the
pin
not just to any square okay
so he's down no he's not down upon okay
so
can he convert this superior ending
strong knight versus bishop
yeah okay so
no rooks on board king's gonna try and
snake around here
yeah white could put a hole punch a hole
into this square oh he could try to
bring the king over here now
put the king right here
all right
okay he's gonna hunt that pawn
one way or the other
and it is a one king and pawn ending
if we get there 23 piece
not easy not easy
as soon as this night moves the king
approaches here i think it might be
objectively a draw
not easy at all
oh he wants this in and then he's gonna
go after this pawn
very nice the timing
very nice
okay what kind of magic
are we gonna have here this should be a
draw
but that night so dangerous
both players could win
he's getting the queen
he's gonna take this one four seconds
just do some time burners
check and then mate wow
22 minutes to go a big win
no fire for rebecca harris 103 15 back
though
how do you come back
down 15 with 22 to go we're gonna find
out
if it's possible michael
international master
in the 41 spot
oh man
okay so some
queen side pressure
down upon
team white down upon this knight far
away from the d4 square
gonna break this down
up next this one now hunting the bishop
first
can you take here first no you're
playing f3
wow what a fancy sequence doesn't want
to take the exchange he's going after
this one oh bishop takes f3
it might have been a miss there
i don't think this one's okay he's
carving out a square on f5
that's a good start
check first
queen enters
hmm
you don't want to
allow queen exchange there
yeah this is covered
i don't think this one's going so well
for team white down on the clock and
position
tricky night
yeah everything's covered this is this
is going to be a really good defender
against any checks too
bishop not such a good defender
we have checks here
oh the bishop is going to block now
white could have some fun
the knight can block though again
covering these nice checks
you take here
the queen's gonna take on e4 now the
queens are off
this is winning for
team black
uh oh
a set back here
yep he throws in the towel
doctor goes down
big loss nardinski loss
103 still back that 15 no fire though
for either
20 minutes to go
okay andrew tang
andrew tang could still make a run
number three spot
let's see
doesn't want to have isolated c pawns
double isolated
okay
centralized queen
where's the knight go to exchange queens
first
is he calculating this
and some maybe
some trick on e3 there okay the knight
is covering c2
uh what a cool sequence i guess this is
forced right you have to allow this
okay
gonna take right away or bypass bypass
he's gonna try and win this one in a
hopefully a simplified position look at
these in-betweeners man
a lot of in-betweeners
okay
oh back rankers
look at that
each side with the past pawn soon as
soon as there's a flight square this is
going to be dangerous
two rooks combined with this pawn and
bishop somehow
influencing the position white wants to
get one rook off oh he's ready to hunt
this pawn now
that was slick
and he's gonna be on the bishop
this one's under control by white
uh winning i'm not so sure
i have to watch out for bishop c4
nice move as soon as king g3 there's h4
yeah once more
there's always this this trick so maybe
you take here and then go after the pawn
oh the king is marching
king stepping up is met with that one
okay he's getting this pawn
wrong caller bishop
just have to take this pawn
yep he's gonna be able to get a draw
andrew's way too fast
yeah stalemate on board
can't win that one oh you could only win
on time but i don't see how you win on
time against andrew tang in that ending
it's too easy moving the king to the
corner square and g8
so still back 15
not in a game yet
narditzky lost three of the last four
drop stone next 17 to go
he needs to make a run right here
running out of time
eight games remaining
nine ten at most we'll see if there's
any quick games in there
bishop pair for black
better structure for white
this move can be pretty irritating at
night on h5 there's no king g7 and
there's pressure on f6
the knight lands
okay here there's no tricks the king
could step up and defend the bishop
but now this is nearby
pressure on f7 not fun to babysit like
this but what can you do
this one it's not a secure home there's
f4
okay
oh that's fancy maybe maybe take the
rook and then go for c4 no he's still
gonna
guard the back rank here
is bishop takes pawn a move
i wonder if bishop takes pawn was maybe
a move there or was that rook still
hanging i i don't recall
oh that one's so slick
go ahead take my bishop
okay
black is gonna take this one this is
secure
connected passers no issue on the clock
wow
there go two f pawns in a blink
rattle the bishop
go here start pushing these guys the
bishops can watch over that one
and from here boom boom
this guy's not
scary enough he's not going over here
so that you don't end up in some
well it's not a mate he could go either
direction with the king he gets that one
pretty fast one
seems like nardiski just got two wins
okay we have naraditsky here again
nardiski wins this he's gonna win the
tournament
that's where we're at with his lead he
has fire
looking at a four with a win
must i i'd say this is this is a must
win
if the doctor's gonna take first
has to win
and if rebecca harris wins he wins the
tournament
let us see
the queen trapped oh my goodness the
queen is trapped
okay he's gonna complicate no he's not a
quick resigner
whoa
dr championstein says hang on
he's still 15 back though
he's still 15 back he does have fire
though
does have fire he caught fire in the
world championship dr
championstein
after that round six game
he caught
fire that marathon game seven hours
45 minutes
game six
okay let's see he's paired against the
number 15 guy fm
he'll rook up and over
rover
bishop here could be challenged with
knight g4 or c4 i like knight g4 there's
no backing off to f2
a big think there for team white
howie how are we dealing with this sweep
the leg this is covered
okay this this rook is in a pin
bishop recapturing
this night now
problems oh
interference
interference
you could take the knight with check
and then take here offer a queen
exchange i think we're gonna have a
resigner a resigner that's a pretty
quick win
maybe just a minute came off the clock
there
112
to 123 he's back 11. he could still do
it clever tactic but fail hang on
no easy games
andrew tang
was waving his finger
not so fast
not so fast
but so far he's having a good result
against andrew tang in this one four to
one
let us see
the bishop hair for black better
structure for white majority for white
on the king side a problem on c7
okay
double rooks get out of the pin and
we're still looking at this one you move
the pawn
that's going to be painful how do you
get out of this situation knight here is
going to hit even harder now
maybe we have to give up the bishop
first no opening up
bishop's eyes he's getting the exchange
oh might a resigner another resigner
that's a pretty quick win and a fast
pairing
116 to 123 definitely within reach
he's only back seven with 12 minutes to
go
it's threatening mate on f7
queenside castles again so he did he
played this last time against midley
yeah it was a queenside castle but both
players went queenside castles
all right let's see
not gonna go queen side this time
king side play first centralized you
have to watch out for some tricks here
there's not yet a pin on the b file
though this is excellent for white these
pawns are way too far advanced oh queen
takes knight
queen takes knight no bishop move with
check
king's on b1
c2 c4 is gonna fall this is excellent
for white
queen takes e problem on this square
watch out for this
watch out for this
game over
game over queen moves queen takes h7
another fast win it felt like three wins
within two minutes
120 with fire 125 rebecca harris
less than 12 to go oh
man
okay
let us see
dimitri gm
a candidate master in the 14 spot having
a very good tournament
in this stacked event
knight on b4 that's ruled out
if pawn takes you could have captured
here and then won the pawn now there's
g2 under fire
to watch out for this at some point
are there some checks now
against the king a little airy over here
some dark square weaknesses he's going
to try and get out
take over the file here there's a check
and now we have this coming up next nope
not so fast
okay it's a little uncomfortable here
right not so easy to defend
he's flicking in f5 and now he's he's
getting at this so instead of going
into some defensive posture he's
activating the bishops
and now he has a more active rook
glue this structure in first no he's
improving the king
here so that you have this one oh now
the rook is kicked off of this ring
okay he still has this pressure now the
rook cannot be
kicked off
plenty of plenty of ways to move along
this
uh fourth rank
he's punching a hole for the king on h4
or f4 in this case he could win this
pawn
yeah this should not be a tall task at
all
up on the clock
and a one rook and pawn position look at
the rook defending both pawns from this
post
the king mops this pawn up maybe you
don't want to take here you boxed out a
little bit
nope
maybe even could have snuck over don't
fall for me
important that that one's landing with
check okay there's no time for team
white where does that put him he's only
one point back with nine and change
remaining wow rebecca harris in the game
against
andrew tang who berserked them
okay this is to put put himself in first
with still plenty of time to go
dr championstein
is he ready to do it
i think he's ready to do it
he's on fire man
in many ways he's on fire
okay
he's okay with giving up that pawn
okay on the rook on f7 the bishop has to
return but then there's that oh
oh
brutal crashing through here
another resigner
just like that look at that stretch one
two three four five six seven in a row
128 with fire it's not over though
rebecca hare is still around only a
point back
a a berserker
no berserk back msb2
now down upon
wow he's going to take this one i don't
see
how do you win how does msb2 win this
one
and down upon
and down on the clock this knight
usually a pretty pretty good piece on
that c6 square but
it's it's under control this knight is a
convenient defender now it's now it's
kicked away
down a piece now team white
a peace and a pawn and the knights are
pouncing
no fancy checks for the night
retreat some defense this is a useful
move there might be some accident
happening on d4 that's the only hope
there goes another night
we got back rank
problems for team white just cover all
the squares nope no soup for you
cut the
cut him off
exchange queens push through
the resigner
he's running away with that he's now up
five how did that happen
wow
eight in a row
he's a wizard
he's a champ
five-time champ drop stone next up
from russia i believe
dropstone
gm from russia
this is uh
this is an interesting
structure uh this is a sensitive point
usually white tries to influence this
pawn
oh that's so fancy look at that
taking advantage of the unprotected
bishop
slick queen move you can't take here you
drop the bishop
if this pawn moves that you give up this
square but you may make this guy budge
if this is ever a hole this knight wants
to get there bishop or brook anything
really wants to get to this square but
now look at this guy wow
glued in on e4
he's a pest there might be some
some tricks like this a mate a queen on
h4 since this bishop's controlling b1
centralize the rook now the knight is
pouncing still there could be some
tricks now i'm not seeing it anymore
with this bishop around on b3 doesn't
seem realistic
queen guards
the king
i don't know if you want to take this
too soon
maybe he's looking at the back rank
stuff maintenance mate threat on
b1
are we stopping that
bishop here
okay oh ho-ho-ho
i'm cutting out your flight square now
the king's gonna go for a walk is he
getting mated
checkmate soon here
possibly oh mate next
check
check me
there we go the doctor
killing it in the end here
is that nine now in a row
136 with fire five minutes to go
no pairing against rebecca harris who
is in berserkland
you gotta win with the berserk i saw
three there
still anything can happen one little
slip up and a couple berserk wins by
narditzky and he could come right back
so giving up this square
space invader pawn
looking to take on f6 a check
flush the knight back and then take here
knight takes f6 has arrived no rook g8
okay in the end how do we
assess this one this is better for white
majority on the king side
fancy
it's a one king and pawn ending it's not
a big deal to have double isolated pawns
you cannot go into a king and pawn
ending but he does
these pawns these three pawns killed
these four
huh
okay that made life a lot easier
thought you needed to keep the knight
around
to try and work some magic
yep
watch out for the tricks oh he could
have got tricked there
if king here he was in pre-move mode
with this
if the king went here he was he was he
pre-moved that
he would have got stalemated
oh
okay wow seven
that would have been a big deal okay
hang on hang on next game
okay he's up seven
but he would have only got two
and he would have been only up five at
this point
so maybe losing this game naraditsky
winning with the berserk
okay
this one looks to be
going in team black's favor
is the queen gonna get trapped
opening up a square oh he's gonna have
to play two minor pieces
oh no he found a way out with that check
fancy yeah that king is on f1
not so fast
i wanted to quickly just take the two
miners
okay now an excellent queen up the
exchange the king is gonna find security
here
not so fast bishop h3
no bishop h3 doubling rooks still need a
flight square for black 2 minutes 40 to
go in the tournament
even on the clock 32 apiece
okay
and now up
i'm gonna have exchanges i think you
want to just get rid of these guys and
then you'll have access to the king
okay he won that one so it really
wouldn't have mattered if that one that
previous game ended up in some stalemate
he's now up 11.
he's down 15.
what maybe just 12 minutes ago and now
he's up 11.
two minutes to go what a
come-from-behind win
manchester united pro the the game the
the final game
for this tournament
i imagine
let us see
so we've had this position before
i think it was their last game where
they had this one
like playing with the better center can
this guy get rolling
let's see
bishop's eyes are opened up now
so if you challenge it's opened up
further but i believe you do have to
eventually challenge this point
when is that going to happen
queen
not so comfortable okay a new square is
produced with b5 multi multi-purpose
prepare to
have some minority attack
vacate b7 for the queen there's a fork
now oh that e5 move hit hard
so he's now up a minor piece one minute
to go
this may not count for the tournament
let's see
still up the
piece down on the clock a little bit
knight is in a pin
exchange nights
clean here
everything's still defended though how
do we get out of this pin
okay glue these guys down
okay now you pick up this pawn and now
the conversion
the conversion the queen could block
we're gonna have a resigner
23 seconds remaining looking at mate
here it's going to just play this one
out mainly
or resign he resigns and that right
there is the final game oh man
what a stretch
in the end how many is that one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve wins in a row to take
the titled arena december 2021
the final tournament
of the year dr championstein takes first
magnus carlson new account
a familiar result
rebecca harris daniel nardiski taking
second with 136 fantastic tournament for
him
and also
clever tactic but fail andrew tang
taking third
fourth spot drop stone fifth spot
arseniy
all gm's the top five and those are your
money winners
right there
okay let's have a look at the first
let's check out the top 100 for this
event
see some of the
other competitors
here's your page three
four
five
six seven
eight
nine
and ten that's your top one hundred
what an awesome event this is a blast to
track
good games all
awesome
you